believe a man can love you but still
cheat yes yeah I do yeah I really do
come on with like long-term cheating or
do you like oh I've slept with this
person and I I've realized I was wrong I
think sometimes they just fall into some
stripper you know yeah
hurricanes all
in a certain type of way he said my
friend he's my read he calls it like a
transfer window like a window he said I
have my windows I do what I do and then
you know what I go back I'm a good dad
I'm a good husband but that's it but
when that window opens it's open and
when it's shut it's shut I don't think
it'll mention neither do I no I'm so
sorry yeah I refuse no mama don't cheat
I just I do think they can sleep with
someone else else and still love you
love me
I think so but not like a long-term
relationship with a whole other family
yeah exactly a double life I don't know
I really think guys can love two women
at the same time yeah I really like I
mean they did it throughout all of
history and then you're gonna you're
gonna tell me that all throughout all of
history when it's 17 it's one man
reproduced for every 17 women that none
of them loved their wives
there's more men than women so
technically like there's lots of women
yeah sorry so they have to double up
yeah reproduce with more women I think
historically 80 of 80 of women have
reproduced historically were only 40 of
men have I think it sounds like two to
one I think sometimes you find out who's
who and you go to funerals and you find
it who's that that sounds awesome yeah
but it's true and that's when you find
out sometimes that the man had a whole
family that nobody knew about and I'm
not saying it's right I'm just saying
that's how the world's always been like
I can't I can't change the world I I
think it happens more with people older
than me than than now it seems to be
like for the old people I'll say like 60
and 70 you always know somebody like
they had somebody down the road they've
got a whole other family that's what you
think oh this oh this is sorry go ahead
go ahead no worries
um I think men or women God has made us
differently
speaking to the mic
um so in Islam men can have up to four
wives
because God know who he's who he's
created men men
they're not they're not like us you know
we're maternal we're more loyal you know
that's what we want from a relationship
and that's what we bring to a
relationship whereas for men they're
more protectors providers they're more
um you know go out there and do the hard
jobs that type of thing so for them what
they want is to spread to put it bluntly
spread their seed and have as many kids
as they can and have as many families as
they can and I'm I mean I I think that's
fine because I think that he can love
talking yeah sorry do you think that he
can love all his wives equally well yeah
I mean I mean that's one of the
concentrates of in in Islam if you're
getting married to more than one wife
you must treat her the both of them or
four of them all four of them equally so
if you buy this one a car you need to
get four cars so if you can't if you're
not that top guy that can do that you
settle and you stay loyal to your one
woman
because when they say I think people get
mixed up when they saw so you can have
four wives you have to be able to afford
four words yes that's why it's a
different yeah you need to treat and the
people the men that I've known that have
got other families
they both have nobody's suffering they
all
and you find that the reason why they
don't want to leave the wife is because
I've been together for years and pension
houses and children in college and
everything grandchildren but I've known
people about a secret family tucked away
and nobody suffers because exactly what
those kids are getting is exactly what
those kids are getting
oh actually actually I have a question
oh this is this is a good question okay
wait okay blessing blessing can you pull
something on the screen are you able to
do that
okay
um Google just go to Google and put in
um put an average guy the first thing
that comes up it's like a guy in a blue
shirt
don't put on the screen until I'll show
you I'll tell you what it is I can see
the screen
the left on the left yeah I have zoom in
okay and then put put
um
what's what's that girl's husband's name
um the Blake Lively's husband uh Brian
Reynolds yeah put Ryan Reynolds on the
screen who is that
I'm just curious he was curious the
answer to this question
um okay so you get you guys get two
options two options
um
yeah put him on the screen and put the
other one tell me when you're ready
foreign
[Laughter]
okay are you ready okay so guy on the
left you can be faithful with him and
have a family or guy on the right you
can be one of his four wives who are you
picking neither no you don't get to pick
either you have to pick one I'm sorry
okay okay I'm just curious who who's
picking who's picking guy on the guy on
the left and he's picking him me all
right one two one two three four five
okay and who's picking Ryan Reynolds
[Laughter]
he's more attractive I don't think
everybody's gonna chase him and who
wants a man that everybody else is going
to want it's like you're not gonna be
attracted to the other guy it can be
improved yeah because looks fade you
know not everyone's going to be pretty
forever some looks like his looks will
improved they can't have no words
I could share a house with Blake Lively
sure no I can't share and also that's
another ick of mine that I can't if
someone if everyone wants you I do not
want you you can be for everyone like
yeah yeah stay safe I hear that and I
don't share either I can't I don't get
that whole concept of like
what is it called when people are in
those open relationships open
relationships yeah there's like a word
for it
yeah I respect it but I can't be
involved in that I don't share my
question earlier they need to stay with
the people that agree with that and they
need to stay with their people yeah I
completely agree with that
okay I'm gonna take a second and read
super chats guys thank you for all the
super chats this show um also
um a little announcement we are doing
the new show schedule it's Thursdays and
Saturdays so that is going to be the
show schedule moving forward
um the only exception to that is the
last weekend of this month so I believe
the 25th
um I'm gonna have a volleyball game so
I'll probably do Friday of that week
um also all super chats are going to be
read over
um what should we do over ten dollars
over ten dollars today so if you have
something you want to read me to read
um yeah Sunday okay sentience men are
required to be gentle with women because
they're not the same as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible